I'm delighted to be able to welcome you
here for the
kolja world fund lecture at Yale this
lecture was established in 1992 by the
late roberto gazeta former chair and CEO
of the coca-cola company and Yale class
of 1953 alumnus professor mom Donnie is
an internationally renowned scholar of
African history politics and society and
is the Herbert Lehman professor of
government at Columbia but he actually
has two day to full-time day jobs he is
also a professor and executive director
of the Institute for Social Research at
Makara University in Kampala in Uganda
and I know that that's real because I've
actually been there and seen him doing
it so it's a great privilege for me to
have professor Mamdani here I first met
him almost 20 years ago at the
University of Cape Town when he at that
time he was the director of the Center
for African Studies there and he's he's
had many appointments in in in Africa
and in in the US and most recently as I
said at Columbia
he was once voted one of the world's
most important public intellectuals by
the u.s. foreign policy and the UK's
prospect magazines and that's only one
of his many distinctions he's written
many books I'm not going to list the
names of all of them perhaps the best
known one is citizen and subject about
the effects of indirect rule in during
the colonial era on on the subsequent
evolution of democracy in Africa and the
indirect versus direct rule but he's
also written more recently book called
good Muslim bad Muslim America the Cold
War and the roots of terror and various
other writings I know he's been spending
a lot of time thinking about
and studying what's and actually even
participating in what's been going on in
South Sudan and we're going to hear some
about that citizen and subject was was
awarded the herskovits prize of the
African Studies Association the US for
the best book in English on on on Africa
in 1996 and it was acclaimed as one of
the hundred best books on Africa written
in the 20th century at the Cape Town
Book Fair so welcome Mahmud the title
that he has chosen for today's lecture
is beyond criminal justice learning from
South Sudan's
and since I wrote this I think I should
be able to see it well I'm delighted to
be here and I want to thank again for
inviting me I have I've divided this
talk into there are some chairs here for
those people were standing
so I've divided this talk into two parts
the first part focuses on the very
particular situation in South Sudan and
it tries to historic eyes it the second
part relates this specific set of
developments to larger questions to
questions in particular one is the
question of impunity accountability
criminal justice and second is the
question of political violence and
political reform excuse me if I read
this because I wanted to get it right
South Sudan exploded into one of the
worst political crises on the African
continent on December 16 2013
thousands were dead by December 30 when
the African Union appointed a
five-person Commission of Inquiry I was
one of the commissioners when the
Commission delivered its report the
following October I wrote a minority
view titled a separate opinion my
principal difference with my fellow
commissioners was conceptual the
majority report sees the violence as
criminal I argued that the violence
the majority report that's the majority
the majority report says the violence is
criminal I argued that the violence
needs to be understood as mainly
political the larger crisis is not just
a breakdown in law and order it's a
political crisis criminal violence can
be traced to the agency of individual
perpetrators political violence however
requires more than just perpetrators
it addresses constituencies
constituencies are mobilized around
issues at the same time violence is
instrumental in mobilizing these same
constituencies I shall begin with an
account of the violence in December 2013
the extreme violence unfolded in two
waves the first from the 16th to the
18th of December in the city of Juba in
a matter of days the violence spread to
three state capitals bore been to and
Malikov in the states of jungle a unity
and Upper Nile together these cover
about 30 percent of the country the
violence ethnically cleans the city of
Juba of its new heir population in just
a matter of three days the motive was
political literally to separate the
civilian population along ethnic lines
to destroy the middle ground and thereby
to polarize the society into us and then
an IDP at the own Mis compound in the
sector known as Juba three told the
Commission they put a knife into what
bound us the political crisis took an
ethnic dimension the violence can be
seen to have morphed through three
stages the first was an outcome of the
power struggle with in Sudan's political
class
this was the opening the violence
followed growing tensions within the
political class export exploding at the
December 1415 meeting of the National
Liberation Council in Juba the tension
grew as three members announced their
intention to contest the top opposition
top position in response President Kiir
removed executive powers from dr. Riek
Machar in April and dissolved the
government in July soon after he began a
tour of the whole of barrel Hazael
giving public speeches that were
televised on South Sudan television I
have now decided to fight my enemies my
nickname is Tiger I have decided to
scratch anyone who opposes me by the
time chairman Kerr called for the
National Liberation Council to meet on
December 14 the stage was set for a
showdown the violence entered its second
stage as armed civilians responded to
officially perpetrated violence armed
civilians from outside of Juba new air
mobilization began on the 17th and 18th
of December it took two forms a
rebellion and enterprising the rebellion
followed the mutiny led by Peter cadet
commander of the 8th division of SPLA a
more spontaneous response came from
county-level youth fighting formations
known as the white army the name refers
to white ash from cow dung with which
the youth smeared their bodies these
youths were fresh from three campaigns
against the adjacent morally militia in
2012 when they heard their relatives
were being killed in Juba the armed
youth that comprised the white army an
estimated 50,000 in all began to move to
Juba the white army is not an army not
even a collection of militias these are
not soldiers but civilians with arms the
difference is in motivation and
discipline unlike with soldiers members
of the white army lack
formal military discipline command or
hierarchy the White Army is motivated by
a deep sense of grievance revenge and
the promise of plunder the White Army
left a trail of pillage carnage and
destruction in the towns and villages
once they swept through as they marched
first to Bent you then to Juba and when
the government army retook these same
towns there was more carnage more
destruction leading to another cycle of
revenge encounter revenge the third
stage of violence was marked by the
entry of outside powers both pledging to
help limit the spread of violence the
Ugandan intervention halted the march of
the white army one miss opened its
compound to protect IDPs from hostile
forces on the government side both were
initially credited with reducing the
level of violence even preventing quote
genocide later however both were accused
of prolonging the crisis the Ugandan
army because it propped up the
government and UNMISS because it
tolerated armed IDPs in the camps there
are two explanations of the violence one
pointing to the internal tribalism the
tribes are naturally warlike and that it
has been common for neighboring tribes
to fight over scarce resources over time
the other points to the external foreign
interference the decisive intervention
of external powers since the onset of
colonialism in late 19th century the
problem with tribalism is an explanation
is that it presumes the crisis is
generated from below the problem with
the externalist explanation is the
assumption that the genesis of the
problem is on the outside and thus the
crisis has been artificially imported
into South Sudanese society I will look
at two key transition periods
colonization in early 20th century and
the comprehensive peace agreement a
century later to argue that neither
internal nor external explain
Asians can on their own shed light on
key periods of transition the challenge
is to understand how the external and
the internal articulate in times of
crises and transition let us begin with
the question of tribalism there are two
major ethnic groups in South Sudan the
Dinka 3.2 million and then we're 1.6
million together they make up 57% of the
South Sudan population the two groups
share a common culture they have similar
languages and both practice and agro
pastoralists
economy the idea that the new era in the
Dinka but the newer most of all are
naturally warlike was first advanced by
the British anthropologist
evans-pritchard
European colonial discourse depicted
South Sudan as a land inhabited by an
array of nomadic tribal groups who
competed over water and pasture this
endless competition was set to generate
periodic cycles of violent attacks
between them evans-pritchard
described the new era as quote a wild
offshoot of the Dinka the problem with
the new heir he wrote was that quote
every new heir the product of hard
upbringing deeply democratic and easily
aroused to violence considers himself as
good as his neighbor and of course
evans-pritchard was describing a deeply
egalitarian culture but the problem he
was describing was less than our problem
then the British colonial problem with
the new heir the new heir were averse to
centralized Authority but if the new
heir did not listen to government
appointed Chiefs they had their own
leaders among them spiritual leaders now
it is known as prophets evans pritchard
saw more promise in the Dinka he found
reassuring their belief that people even
within the same family are quote not as
equal as sticks in a matchbox nor quote
have the same
as the herds of giraffes the British
political problem was how to establish
internal sovereignty over mobile and
armed semi pastoral communities with a
tradition that combined autonomy with
coexistence in a multi-ethnic region the
problem was how to achieve sole monopoly
over instruments of violence and
processes of conflict resolution and
thereby establish an effective internal
sovereignty in the country
the British solution was to mediate
colonial rule that is internal
sovereignty through a series of
internally self-governing tribally
defined political entities this involved
drawing hard boundaries around ethnic
identities and then to politicize these
in a series of steps first to define
ethnicity as an exclusive group identity
second to identify ethnicity with a
bounded homeland third to put each
homeland under the administration of an
appointed ethnic authority fourth to
give that authority the right to
administer land and adjudicate internal
conflicts fifth to legitimate the
absolute power of this Authority
unaccountable by claiming unaccountable
authority to be customary and finally to
insulate that authority from popular
pressure by backing it most uncustomary
with the power of the colonial state the
politicization of ethnicity into a micro
version of the nation state known as
tribe led to two consequences the first
was a fragmentation of South Sudan along
tribal lines in one local authority
after another those claiming to be
indigenous to the land fought those who
they said lacked the customary right to
natural resources and who in turn
demanded their own ethnic homeland
this was the identitarian aspect of
tribalism ii was a structural tension
between an egalitarian society and the
hierarchical administrative structure
known as the native authority
this gave democratic content to the
tribal question the tension gave rise to
periodic revolts if competition and
rivalry over scarce resources marked
relations between Dinka and we're before
colonialism these intensified with fixed
boundaries under colonial rule and yet
every step in the political development
of the region was made possible by a
coming together of Dinka and new air in
a common cause this was true in 1983 as
it had been in 1924 historians date the
beginning of the Sudanese national
movement in the 1920s with the formation
of the anti British white flag brigade
founded by two South Sudanese Muslims
one Dinka ali abdul latif and the other
new heir abdel fattah el mas both became
known for their role in the 1924 armed
uprising against British rule in Sudan a
similar story is told of how
collaboration between a Dinka could be
no kuan-yin bull and in where william
knew on Benny
both former Sudan army officers led to
the 1983 mutiny in boar and a yoke and
the founding of spla in the onset of the
second phase of the north-south struggle
which ended with the signing of the CPA
in January 2005 two demands above all
drove the mobilisation of political
groups in South Sudan
one was the call for ethnic solidarity
in ethnic representation the other was
the direction to be taken by the new
power a new Sudan or any independent
South Sudan the first liberation war of
the unyaunya was organized around the
demand for an independent South Sudan
for John Garang who founded the SPLA and
led it for two decades the demand for an
independent South Sudan had made it
possible for Khartoum to isolate the
South by rallying the rest of the
country against secession Garang
concluded that to succeed the SPLA
needed to define an all Sudan objective
around which to rally discontented
forces throughout the country thereby to
turn the tables politically on the power
in Khartoum and two isolated events
proved wrong right the SPLA s greatest
victories were in the border areas just
across the north south boundary Southern
Kordofan Blue Knight nuba mountains to
the south apiary and in the western part
of the country Darfur where its example
led to the formation of a parallel
movement for autonomy grants great
contribution was to inspire a vision
that made possible a single rallying
point around which to mobilize
discontent throughout Sudan not just
South Sudan his single most important
failing was to subordinate this vision
to the struggle for power and personal
ambition faced with the demand for
reform he moved to consolidate power the
result was that every major struggle
whether ideological or personal led to a
spilling of more blood and every
subsequent bloodletting was resolved
through a cosmetic power sharing
strategy a sharing of positions and
resources which turned out to be no more
than an interlude between bloody bugs
and yet the strategy seemed to be
working
the reason was external so long as
Garang in those who followed him
accommodated themselves to the demands
of external powers whether during the
era of the Cold War or more recently the
war on terror they could count on full
support from the outside this was the
other side of Garang Garang as a Western
proxy be lying his reputation as a
leader beyond criticism
unqualified Western support rendered
Garang immune against internal demands
for reform the result was to stall
political reform and institutional
development within South Sudan this
failure contaminated all institutions
but above all the army we shall see this
dialectic external support blocking
internal political reform unfold
repeatedly first in 1991 then in 2013
let me begin with 1991 1991 erupted when
two senior spla commanders Lama Kohl in
Upper Nile and Riek Machar in NASA along
the ethiopian border and a third gordon
king called for the replacement of John
Garang as leader the commanders
mobilized around two demands that Garang
had tied the SPLA too closely to the
government of Minister Hailemariam in
Ethiopia and the D Theo pian support was
being used to forestall the demand for
an independent South Sudan and for
internal reform in the fighting that
ensued much ours forces are said to have
slaughtered around 2,000 Inca civilians
broad-based before the Boer massacre the
nasa group narrowed into a more or less
exclusively in you air affair after the
spilling of blood and went on to sign an
agreement with the Sudan government in
Khartoum as more groups joined there was
close collaboration with her tone making
it possible for the Sudan government to
begin pumping oil from South Sudan
fields in unity and Upper Nile the Haram
peace agreement between Riek Machar in
the South Sudan government broke down in
2001 mature and some of his forces
returned to the SPLM but the rest
led by paulina motive and other generals
stayed behind in Khartoum and formed the
South Sudan defense forces an
organization that grew into a formidable
force under the patronage of the Soudan
army in the decade and a half between
1991 and 2006 before the last of the
rebel forces led by Paulina Marti
returned to the four fold of SPLA there
was a pragmatic reconciliation between
communities on the ground after all
people have no choice but to live next
to one another these multiple
initiatives were driven by an
inescapable fact neighboring communities
had no choice but to accommodate one
another sooner or later the ground-level
process took place both inside
communities and between neighboring
communities the initiative came from
local leaders usually Chiefs or
religious leaders and involve the active
participation of youth and women in the
decade that followed 1991 the best-known
organized effort at community level
reconciliation was known as moonlit
named after the town in Barajas al where
the Dinkin where West Bank peace and
reconciliation conference was held from
27th February to 8th March 1999 moonlit
had three limitations
together these highlight the limitations
of what is known as traditional
reconciliation the first was spatial
though it covered multiple communities
and was trans local the one lit process
did not cover all regions torn apart by
the 1991 violence it affected only one
side of the Nile it involved the Dinka
of Barajas el but not the ball Dinka the
second was structural one league bore
the hallmarks of the forces that drove
it churches and Chiefs each had
developed as an ethnic institution
during the colonial period Britain had
divided the south into zones and
distributed each zone to a different
denomination Presbyterians got Upper
Nile Catholics got Upper Barajas ala
Anglicans were awarded equatorial it is
only after the Sudan government passed
the 1962 missionary
and expelled all missionaries that the
leadership of ethnic churches began to
cooperate under a single umbrella known
as the Council of Churches this history
sketches both the sectarian beginning of
church organization and the imperative
to transcend it in the face of
government repression it also underlines
the inadequacy of the church as a viable
force for national reconciliation the
same can be said of Chiefs who dispensed
what was called traditional justice the
third limitation was political the scope
of traditional justice is limited to
community-based conflicts not conflicts
that arise from state defined
sovereignty thus traditional justice as
little to say about the relationship
between state and society and thus about
individual or group rights in the
framework of a nation state the
situation following December 15 has
highlighted the limitations of
traditional justice in the face of mass
violence and large-scale
ethnic cleansing including mass
appropriation of property such as
grabbing of houses in urban areas and
land in the countryside as a pragmatic
process bonnet peppered over papered
over deep divisions opened up by 1991
the reconciliation that followed was
driven by short term considerations and
was unable to avert the disaster in 2013
the impetus for these divisions came not
from tribes in society but armed
formations in the proto state structure
as indeed had been the case in 1991
South Sudan's claim to internal
sovereignty lay in the integrity and
cohesion of a single institution the
State Army yet when South Sudan became
independent in 2011 there was not one
army but at least three the post 1991
SPLA the mature group which had returned
in 2002 and the multiplet s SDF which
returned
in 2006 the SPLA is not a standing army
even if its organization may suggest so
soldiers are mobilised for each
operation and disbanded after it in its
looseness of formation the SPLA
resembles the white army the only
difference is that the SPLA has a formal
command structure and some training
which make for minimum discipline in
december 2013 the SPLA was set to
comprise roughly two hundred and forty
thousand soldiers two hundred thousand
military and forty thousand reserves
including those handicapped and retired
and still on the payroll sir
but the SPLA did not have a full roster
of its soldiers what the SPLA does have
is a roster of commanders with each
commander having his roster of soldiers
under his command but the central
command does not have access to these
individual lists in other words the SPLA
is not a single integrated formation a
senior military officer summed up the
situation bodyguards of Salva were
mainly Dinka of Rick and Paulina Mahtob
mainly knew where majority of Ministers
also had personal militias even
prominent politicians like lamech all
have their own army the s SDF led by
Paulina Mahtob was also like the SPLA a
loose conglomeration of village based
militias comparable to the SPLA in
numbers with the merger paulina motive
became the deputy commander of SPLA
under Salva Kiir what is the number of
soldiers in the SPLA can only be guessed
at there is relative certainty as to the
number of generals in the SPLA command
they were reportedly 700 generals at the
time of the December 15 crises they
included four four-star generals nine
three-star generals a hundred major
generals and countless number of
brigadier General's the ratio of
generals to soldiers in the SPLA is
reportedly higher than that
any other state army in the world Salva
Kiir big tent policy maintained yes ple
as a collection of separate militias and
postponed any reform of the military
sector the only thing they shared in
common was that they all drank from the
same borehole the government Treasury
though couched as a grand reconciliation
the big tent policy encouraged the
notion that peace had to be paid for it
encouraged militias to bargain for peace
and then turn rebellion into a
bargaining chip those with a grievance
rebuilt only to return with a reward
seen by all concerned as the price for
keeping peace the reconciliation policy
turned into an incentive to rebel take
the example of David yo-yo a former
school teacher who led a male militia
called the SPLA cobra into several
rebellions each time moving back and
forth between Juba and Khartoum the most
recent rebellion was followed by
negotiations that integrated this group
into spla David yo-yo was made a general
commanding an area with a population of
120,000 27,000 civilians according to
the 2008 census the Minister of Defense
explained the new status of David yo-yos
militia quote it will be autonomous and
under the office of the president not a
state and yet it will have the powers of
a state brigadier general my year my own
SPL a commander at the military camp in
Bor told the Commission David Yahya has
been given what he wanted his troops are
under him but nominally inside the SPLA
we do not know where his troops are now
this is not the first time he has joined
her tomb before and come to us not once
but many times a senior commander summed
up the status of spla on the EO of 15th
december 2013
everytime we integrate someone declares
in Khartoum that we have a militia we
integrate them and give them a rank
most of these militias are illiterate
led by illiterate Major Generals even
today we have not integrated them it was
like dealing with ng
all with their own leadership each
sponsored by a different country
we tried to demobilize them but that was
difficult
you cannot demobilize someone who has a
gun you give him money on the ddr when
the money is finished he will go back to
the bush his small arms proliferated the
society got further militarized most
soldiers lived in civilian neighborhoods
with their families and their own guns
not in barracks demobilized soldiers
kept their guns the commander in the
field was literally a dictator there was
no appeal against the commander's
decision living among civilians soldiers
created detention centres for civilians
and these two proliferated this
factionalized army was called upon to
provide political leadership to the new
state and society so convinced was the
troika and the international community
the troika is the US Britain and Norway
and the international community they led
the primary contradict so convinced were
they that the primary contradiction in
Sudan was between Arab and African and
that the main danger for an independent
South Sudan would be war with Sudan to
the north that all key decisions were
taken with this single danger in mind
generals were cherry-picked and
installed as ministers or governors or
heads of civil service divisions
generals became top politicians the
military commander in chief became the
civilian president a general became the
Speaker of Parliament and brigadiers
became governors my thesis is simple the
problem in South Sudan did not spring
from society its Genesis lay in the
proto state created hothouse fashion by
a group of three states known as the
troika the US the UK and Norway the
articulation between the internal the
three different armed formations that
comprised the SPLA and the external hope
is not mine
and the external being the three western
states that form the troika reinforced
the worst tendencies amongst internal
armed groups making them averse to
internal reform and prone to a military
resolution of internal differences as
with fish South Sudan rotted from the
head down there are two major examples
of self-determination secession in
post-colonial Africa Eritrea and South
Sudan Eritrea independence followed a
military victory against the ruling dirt
in Addis Ababa but there was no military
victory in South Sudan the external
factor was decisive more than any other
state South Sudan was a child of the war
on terror the major reason explaining
its creation was the real fear that
Sudan would be the next target of u.s.
aggression in a post 9/11 era that had
begun with the invasion of Afghanistan
in Iraq why the government of Sudan
agreed to hold an independence
referendum in the south a secondary
reason was the presumption among
Islamist rulers in the north that
Southern independence would strengthen
northern solidarity by getting rid of a
predominantly non-islamic part of the
country 9/11 led both to deeper US
interest and involvement in the Sudanese
Civil War and to greater Sudanese
susceptibility to increased American
pressure the combination led to the
signing of the comprehensive peace
agreement the CPA in 2005 the troika was
the real force behind the CPA the troika
preferred to be known as friends of 'god
he got being the Intergovernmental
authority for development comprising six
east african countries it is the troika
that put resources and muscle behind the
guard including strategic guidance for
armed groups it is the troika they
decided that a k47
tottering soldiers and their commanders
be handed power in 2005 even though they
had not won the war did not constitute a
coherent force and had no more than us
civilian base the SPLA was the CPA was
premise on a military assumption there
are only those with the capacity to wage
war have the right to determine the
terms of the peace since the talks
excluded the political opposition in
both the north and the south they
rendered the political opposition
illegitimate in both halves of the
country doubling is both army income and
movement the SPLA SPLM in the south
emerged as the precocious double of
national congress party in the north the
cps strengthened the armed dictatorship
in the north and introduced one in the
south following the referendum south
sudan became autonomous in 2005 and
independent in 2011 South Sudan has long
been used to basking in the halo
conferred on goes officially
acknowledged as victims of terror in an
era driven by the assumption that a
victim can do no wrong it was coddled
and absolved of any responsibility that
this governing class should seem
incapable of reform on its own should
not come as a surprise the double
standards were evident to all possibly
even to those who apply these whereas
the ruling party in the north was
rightly and wrongly criticized for
electoral malpractice and fraud in the
elections of April 2010 there was not
even muted criticism when it came to
similar practices by the SPLM in the
South that same year when the referendum
on self-determination returned a 99.8%
yes vote in the South the international
community lauded the result when they
would have poo-pooed a similar result
anywhere else in the world but when the
SPLA split in nearly two halves in
December 2013 each determined to devour
the whole or devour the other both the
Western press and Western governments
were at a loss the fallback explanation
tribalism
evoked the conventional wisdom that
Africans may be quick at learning the
arts of war but seem genetically
resistant to learning the arts of peace
by reinforcing the most negative of the
legacies of the liberation war the
aversion to internal reform is the
outcome of a political process the CPA
laid the seats of the peasant crisis a
leading opposition politician in Juba
contrasted the CPA assured in by the
troika in 2005 with the Addis Ababa
agreement concluded by the numeri
government in 1972 quote the agreement
in 1972 was negotiated by a party called
s SL m which did not carve out for
itself all the power we had a vibrant
but plural power even though there was a
single party in Khartoum
but SPLM got power through an agreement
not through elections after excluding
everyone else they began to exclude
themselves if the CPI gave birth to a
political dictatorship of all armed
groups the Society it commanded rapidly
turned into an international dependency
just as all divergent political forces
were excluded from the political life of
the country so were all those in society
without an spla Allegiance marginalized
in the state controlled administrative
sector in the absence of a functioning
civil service ministries were occupied
rather than run by generals and their
relatives a participant in the caucus of
women in Juba explained quote employment
in the ministry from the Director
General to the cleaner is for only one
tribe when a ministry is appointed his
first question is how many people from
his tribe are there in the ministry if
he thinks them not enough then some
others are dismissed without due process
and tribes persons are appointed the
same reasons are given each time we
fought you and you did not you were with
the djellaba we will be DSP L M we will
with the Red Army you were not more and
more trained and experienced cutter were
denied employment in the state sector on
grounds ranging from not having
participated in the struggle
- not hurt - having worked in the north
- speaking Arabic but not English the
result was an artificial scarcity of
human power donors fill the gap the
result was a total disjunction between a
donor directed technical cutter and the
political leadership of South Sudan on
the one hand
lots of people were trained on the other
few were integrated into government
structures so the shortage of trained
human resource became even more acute in
charge of shepherding the transition
from CPA in 2005 to independence in 2011
one miss put forth both an agenda and a
rationale for institutionalizing South
Sudan as an international dependency as
un paternalism fed South Sudanese
dependence the UN gave itself an
all-embracing mission State Building and
nation-building leading the UN team was
a former Norwegian state minister ms
Hilda Johnson with the formal title
special representative of the Secretary
General in charge of State Building and
nation-building srst Johnson commanded
10,000 UN personnel 7,000 military and
3,000 civilian she was the equivalent of
a colonial governor what then is the
problem and the way for this was at the
heart of my disagreement with the
majority in the Commission the
disagreement focused on two issues
criminal accountability in its relation
to rule of law and political reform is a
way to establish internal sovereignty
I'll begin with criminal accountability
the response of the UN and the African
Union to extreme violence in South Sudan
was to broker a patchwork agreement that
redistributed official positions among
those responsible for the carnage that
began on December 16 2013
this initiative evaded the question of
account
how to create a viable and accountable
structure of power in South Sudan this
question has been at the heart of the
South of South Sudan politics since 1991
more than any other event it is 1991
that has shaped the collective psyche of
the present generation in South Sudanese
it is noteworthy that this source of
national trauma did not originate from
the struggle against Khartoum but from
the failure to handle internal conflicts
within SPLA 1991 was not resolved it was
deferred a member of the caucus of women
urged the Commission to acknowledge the
meaning of the 1991 Boer Massacre quote
a big number of Dinka were killed there
was no accountability efforts for
reconciliation but no truth the wound is
still there in the hearts of many Dinka
the violence now is for me a
continuation of the 1991 massacre 1991
is an argument against a parish against
a power-sharing arrangement at the
expense of truth and accountability it
is an argument against impunity the
interminable talk of the need for rule
of law in Africa is remarkable for the
absence of any reference to equality
before the law take for instance the
proposal to create a hybrid court to
hold accountable those charged with
responsibility for mass violence they
began December 13 2013 in South Sudan
why should this responsibility be
limited only to South Sudanese why not
the framers of the CPA given that the
culture of impunity was entrenched
during this failed transition why not
srst Johnson who had command over 10,000
UN personnel of which 7000 were military
during those fateful three days in
December where anywhere up to 20,000
civilians were slaughtered the killing
of newer civilians began after the armed
confrontation between soldiers in the
presidential guard
had ended after nuaire soldiers had left
Juba miss Johnson gave orders to open
the gates of the UN compound in Juba two
civilians fleeing their killers but did
not intervene to stop the killing
outside those gates should we not
understand the failure to stop the
slaughter of civilians is a latter-day
history bronica 3166 deaths were
documented in Srebrenica there is not
documented tally of those killed in Juba
from 15 to 18 December 2013 but the
estimates go up to 20,000 with 7,000
troops in South Sudan under her command
was not the failure to intervene clear
violation of a mandate to protect
civilians and thus a crime against
humanity what if anything had the UN
learnt from Rwanda and from Srebrenica
where is the demand for criminal
accountability is not applied to
international officials there is no
hesitation in applying it to the highest
elected leaders within Africa in how
many countries in the world can you try
an elected president or even try elected
officials in the US you have to impeach
an elected president before putting that
person on trial in other words you
cannot try that person as a president
you can only try that person as a
civilian the assumption is that to try a
sitting president is put the sovereignty
of the country on trial this is no less
true of Africa the demand to try elected
African presidents is a direct challenge
to Africa's sovereignty recently his and
Habra was tried in Senegal but as a
former president not as a sitting
president that makes all the difference
to try a sitting president is not simply
to try an individual but also to put the
sovereignty of the country on trial
in the absence of equality before the
law the call for an end to impunity has
been politicized and turned into an
instrument of Western power to
subordinate African sovereignty when it
comes to public office political
accountability has to precede criminal
accountability who should be held
responsible politically for the extreme
violence that has destroyed tens maybe
hundreds of thousands of lives in South
Sudan since December 2013 in my view two
groups above all first the troika for
its decisive role in framing an
agreement that set up a politically
unchallenged armed power in South Sudan
second the pre July 2013 cabinet of the
government of South Sudan for the
political crises that led to the
political meltdown on December 15 2013
why is it that no one is talking of
holding the troika accountable for the
devastation of life in South Sudan let's
take an analogy from the marketplace the
law of competition then in the market is
that just as you reap the benefits of a
profitable investment so you must pay
the price for a loss making investment
but in the era of monopolistic
competition this law does not apply to
the biggest enterprises just as it is
said that some banks are too big to fail
there's the same hole in the political
world that some are simply too big to be
held accountable rule of law is about
holding the rich and the powerful
accountable for their actions in the
absence of equality before the law rule
of law turns into a mask for the rule of
the strong in short warlordism because
the same rules do not apply to all
states the contemporary international
legal order reinforces the rule of the
powerful not the rule of law the demand
for an end to impunity is today at the
forefront of the call for an
international regime of criminal
besides the fact that its application is
not consistent but is politicized there
are two further problems with this
demand the first is that it translates
the call for a universal norm into a
one-size-fits-all prescription
regardless of context the second is that
it reduces all violence to criminal
violence making it a matter of strictly
individual responsibility as is well
known the one-size-fits-all dogma began
in the sphere of economic policy and was
enforced as a series of structural
adjustment programs by the Washington
Consensus in the 1980s its destructive
effects are now both well-documented and
widely acknowledged next the single
formula application moved to the domain
of politics calling for a single
standardized institutional arrangement
regularly party based elections is the
sum and substance of democratic politics
today that same single formula remedy
rules the roost in the field of conflict
resolution and transitional justice
prescribing a single across-the-board
remedy criminal accountability criminal
justice is today heralded as the gold
standard the antidote for all
manifestations of extreme violence in
the field of justice the single formula
approach makes a single simple
declaration a crime has been committed
and its perpetrators must be identified
and punished the question of justice is
reduced to an issue of crime and
punishment the rationale is that justice
must be based on universal principles
but there's a difference between
following universal principles and
adopting single formula solutions the
difference is one of context context is
not the opposite of universal value or
standard context is an understanding
that any concrete event is an outcome of
multiple causes historical political
moral economic etc the decisive issue in
this case is political
the mainstream tendency that identifies
justice with criminal justice and
criminal justice with punishing
individual perpetrators even in cases of
mass violence fails to distinguish
between criminal and political violence
in neoliberal fashion it individualizes
both the explanation and the
responsibility for mass violence whereas
criminal violence may be linked to the
agency of individual perpetrators
political violence needs more than
perpetrators above all it needs the
constituency the link between political
violence and constituencies mobilized
around it is one of issues and thus
raises the question of political reform
it is common sense that conflict takes
place at not just the individual roles
but also at the group level just as
courts that try individual perpetrators
need to apply the same rule to all
thereby ensuring equality before the law
the political ground over which group
contests are played out needs to be
defined by commonly accepted rules even
if this is not even if the this is not
on a level playing field the rules need
to be accepted by the principle
contestants in modern language if we
refer to the ensemble of these rules as
a constitution in colonial context these
rules were most often formulated by the
colonial power but were discussed and
debated in constitutional conferences
one example of such a conference is the
Lancaster House Conference in the case
of British colonies the CPA was not
comparable to the prototype Lancaster
House Conference that half a century ago
prepared the ground for the independence
of many a British colony the closest
development to a Lancaster House
conference in South Sudan was the 2010
all South Sudan political parties
conference
held that October the old South Sudan
political parties conference ended with
a call for a transitional government of
national unity composed of all political
parties headed by Salva Kiir it included
an agreement to hold a constitutional
conference in another election in two
years but after the referendum SP le
revised the constitution and gave
themselves the right to rule until 2015
before independence SPLA was open to
negotiation with internal forces whose
cooperation and support it needed after
independence SPLA saw these forces as a
handicap to exercising power a formality
it could dispense with now that it
enjoyed firm support from the troika let
us keep in mind the fact that South
Sudan has never had an election Salva
Kiir was elected vice president of Sudan
he was never elected president of a
state called South Sudan to think of
South Sudan as a failed state is to
overlook the simple fact that the very
political and institutional foundation
for the existence of a state as a
political process that legitimates a
sovereign power and the creation of an
administrative technical and legal
infrastructure does the means for
exercising that power that has yet to be
forged in South Sudan rather than a
failed state South Sudan was a failed
transition South Sudan does not need
another quick fix response to a growing
political crisis it needs a political
transition the political process that
was cut short after the 2010 meeting of
political parties should be given a new
life what should be the content of this
transition and the whose authority
should it unfold what should be the role
of members of the pre July 2013 cabinet
in this process who should ensure order
during this period these are some
questions for further reflections
questions with which I would like to
close this thank you
I'm sure they're gonna be a lot of
questions I wonder if I could started
off with one talking about the
difference between political and
criminal violence called to my mind the
TRC the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission in south after South African
transition which also made such a
distinction but and this is by way of
getting unit to draw you out a little
bit more on on the difference in what's
really at stake in the difference
because as you I'm sure well remember
the criterion for amnesty used by the
TRC was convincing the Commission is
that that perpetrators were acting from
a motive of political violence and you
had to convince them of other things too
but but if you couldn't convince them
you were acting from a motive of
political violence she wouldn't amnesty
which might be taken to suggest that
that political violence is somehow more
acceptable than criminal violence now as
I recall they didn't fully define what
they meant by political violence in that
context except that it to some extent it
was in the eye of the beholder or the
commissioners they had to be persuaded
but thinking sort of thinking aloud
while listening to you it seems to me
that that the premise behind the
distinction wasn't so much that
political violence is in some sense more
justifiable or defensible or less less
heinous than criminal violence but
rather that since this was part of a
since the TRC was part of a process of
political reconciliation
that this was the mechanism of
accountability
instead of criminal culpability and so I
mean is that how would you reason your
way through this okay is it that before
they can be political accountability
there must be a transition that includes
some sort of political reconciliation so
that that issue of accountability simply
can't be put now or is there some other
way you would think about that
comparison at one level TRC was like a
court process in the sense that he
decided whether you were guilty or
innocent and then it decided on the
nature of the guilt and whether you
should be pardoned or not but another
level TRC was part of a larger process
in South Africa which I think is very
interesting and and very applicable but
has been sidestepped
completely the South African case has
been seen as exceptional and the
exceptionalism of the South African case
has been linked to the exceptional
character of Mandela's personality now
the interesting thing about the South
African case is apartheid was
universally condemned as a crime against
humanity there was not a single person
convicted in court
even in a case like steve biko
whose killers were well known when the
case was taken by the Beco family to the
highest court in the land the court
dismissed it saying that at stake is a
higher good and that higher good is the
political reform so yes at the heart of
the transition from at the heart of
dismantling political and legal aparte
not social apartheid but political and
legal apartheid at the heart of it was
not the TRC it was not truth in
reconciliation it was political reform
give and take and part of that
give-and-take process was that instead
of excluding from the political process
those who are who have allegedly
committed crimes the whole point of the
political process should be to include
them in it that's the only way you could
reach an agreement so the government
recognized the liberation movements
legalize them including the Communist
Party these movements recognize the
government is the legal government of
South Africa and recognize even the
broader bond okay so political inclusion
was the point not exclusion of those
indicted with criminal responsibilities
that's what I'm proposing I'm proposing
that the political process comes first
unless you address the political
question you cannot have rule of law
rule of law does not exist on its own it
needs an accountable power structure and
without a rule of law you cannot have
criminal accountability the process is
completely reversed so it's very
interesting the South African government
now leaving the ICC right and I haven't
read much about it but the only
statement I read was that they said they
wanted to have the option of peaceful
settlement of conflicts and I think that
hits the nail on the head it's
absolutely right if you want the
conflict to be solved settled by courts
Court is a site where winner takes all
you're either guilty or innocent but the
political process cannot be aside where
winner takes all the political process
is necessary precisely because there's
been no winner precisely because there
was no military victory so you can't
have a Nuremberg so winner cannot take
all the political process is necessary
because we have decided that we must
find a way of living together but I
think we're being made to believe that
justice is simply criminal justice and
that that's the way for
based violence is that it illegitimate
us the individuals involved and
basically takes away their claim to
representing the group which then
creates preconditions for reconciliation
between groups
how would you engage with that argument
I would engage with it in in two
different ways if you think that the
violence is the result of individual
agency maybe but the problem is that in
all these instances of extreme violence
we have cycles of violence we don't
violence is not a standalone event and
if you try and understand why the cycle
of violence you have to move from the
individual to an issue you have to
highlight a grievance you have to bring
to the forefront the link between the
individual and a constituency around
which whether that constituency is
actively participating because I don't
mean perpetrators I mean a constituency
which may include perpetrators I'm sure
it does but it's more than perpetrators
so
I'm saying these are political crimes
what role Commission's of inquiry in a
new commissioners been relatively asking
you to evaluate my own work
that's a tough one the way
well I think there are two ways to think
of Commission's of inquiry one is to
think of them as a as a as a political
site so a site for contest and think of
commissioners as representing
constituencies and representing points
of views and therefore a good commission
of inquiry would be one that would
include all major all contesting points
of views within it that's one way to see
it the other way to see it is to see it
as a as a coming together of individuals
who have expertise in different matters
who are not political who are not
contaminated by politics in a sense and
who will sort of look at this completely
from the outside and and would give you
a response so in the South African case
if you look at the TRC one of the things
that always I found interesting about
the TRC was that in the the members of
the TRC excluded any historian any
political scientist the members of the
TRC were all the trauma experts or legal
experts or religious these were the
three groups represented on the TRC but
the historians the political scientists
were in the backup team so so the clears
he tried to find some kind of a midway
ground to to have them available but not
influential in a sense it also has to do
with who does the appointing so so if
the appointing does not include the
major contesting parties that's also can
be problematic but I can't tell you
anything more than that
yes sir
thank you I was amazed by how deep the
distinction between sequent criminal
violence can go in laid out support
future steps for reconciliation and
peace building but I was wondering if
the distinction is actually still active
when we think about meetings is there a
difference between a political victory
and a criminal victory and in not trying
to achieve a certain level restorative
justice doesn't the distinction actually
they lived giving closure and
restoration to people who actually lost
their always during very complex so is
there a distinction between the points
of agreement over to again let's go back
to the South African example again the
TRC mmm-hmm had to discuss who is a
victim right and they came up with a
list of I think 20,000 plus individuals
as victims and I said to myself how can
this be if you just count the number of
people who were forced to carry
passbooks Millions
if you count those who were victims of
forced removals my tractor's coming and
knocking down your house etc billions so
how can you just have 20,000 plus
victims and and the TRC defined as
victim somebody who whose bodily
integrity was violated somebody who was
raped who was killed who was tortured
that's it nobody else is a victim okay
um so who is a victim that's the first
question
so because the point is this that that
if you want a victim where you can
identify an individual perpetrator then
you need a victim the way the TRC
identified that victim because to say
that victims of forced removals or those
who target so forceful moons targets of
pass laws etc were victims is then to
say that the perpetrator is the state
it's to identify a completely different
purpose
you cannot individualize anymore okay
the the criminal proposition calls for
an individual ization or victim and
perpetrator both of them if more than
that you go beyond it to say that well
if the redistribution of resources works
completely based on racial lines etc
then you have victim communities okay I
mean what where what is a victim that's
the first question second question is
even after you resolve the question of
what is a victim I I am NOT very
convinced that the way forward is to
look for victims justice in fact I'm not
at all convinced because victims justice
I think to me has the smell of revenge
it has the smell of turning tables
upside down right the whole point of
moving beyond the part of it I think was
twofold one was to find a way forward
not just for victims but for
perpetrators for bystanders for the term
I use is survivors for survivors but the
second was to recognize that date way
forward would be untenable unless you
moved from political justice to social
justice the entire situation in South
Africa over the last few
is testimony to them right to me it's
not I don't read that situation as
questioning the credibility the the the
legitimacy of the transition that
happened I still think the transition
that happened was
first of all involved a measure of
realism that the state hadn't won the
war and the liberation movements had not
made a revolution right so it had to be
a compromise so the compromise was
dismantled legal and political apartheid
which led us to the next phase which is
social apartheid which is how are you
now going to deal with the question of
social justice and that's what the
student movement is about that's what
the larger picture in South Africa is
about
for the troika shame I mean just just
just just public disclosure as to their
role right I mean even accountability
has to take a form which allows us to
move forward
okay cannot be vindictive right but
first is that second is that if you're
going to move forward in in in in South
Sudan
you will need resources from these
fellows they have the resources and from
some others you need the resources but
you need the resources without the
control and in that shaming that public
acknowledgement should play some role in
it right so I mean I don't want to give
facile answers to you know what but I
have given facile answers in other
contexts
in the context of various international
actors they are telling the different
political actors who are pushing for at
least some kind of federalism or perhaps
some kind of independence they're always
told by these sort of international
suitors look at South Sudan South Sudan
is a total mess independence is not ever
going to be the answer you have to work
in these other kinds of models so those
are the lesson the things to be learned
is independence try to work things out
we're not going to try that mistake
again
and I think I mean your point is very
well taken that it's this interplay
between internal and external actors
circumstances in conflict but I was
wondering we you mentioned that these
two examples of self-determination in
Africa are South Sudan and Eritrea we
haven't talked very much about Eritrea
but in Eritrea that kind of
international engagement certainly from
UN actors and those kinds of people is
much much less okay um a month before
Helen Johnson's book was published
I had a debate with her on Norwegian
radio station and I said to her in the
debate why should you not be tried for
crimes against humanity she was so upset
if if the interviewer were not there
she would have heard her upsetness would
have had different expressions from this
profession so yes there is it there's a
degree of shaming but it's it's just
Hilary Johnson is not responsible for
the CPA okay I mean this has to this has
to include the CPA and and and it has to
be brought not within the framework of
the role of one individual from the
weakest of the troika no way but the
role of the strongest of the troika in
the war on terror so that's first of all
whether one can draw a lesson from South
Sudan that independence doesn't work I
am skeptical because as I said him I
think context matters context is
important the aerotrain in the South
Sudanese cases were different because in
Eritrea there was a military victory in
South Sudan there wasn't which is why
the overwhelming importance of the
external involvement himself to that and
why there was hardly any in in in in
there was some in Eritrea but not not as
much but the South African case it is
interesting because there was no
military victory and yet of course
because the Cold War had ended the the
the measure of internal autonomy over
the resolution of it because the US was
no longer scared that the ANC would turn
out to be a Trojan horse of of an
external power there was greater
internal autonomy that that that
historical moment was important and I
think that that's important to
appreciate South Sudan in Eritrea
look if you take the larger picture look
at the region Sudan Ethiopia Somalia all
these three states have split
all of them northern Somalia and Somalia
Eritrea is European Sudan South Sudan
all of them have split and one needs a
measure of thinking about why this no
other part of Africa I said this kind of
an outcome what is it what are the lines
along which they have they have split
what what what can what can we learn
from it in a sense I don't think I have
a response to it right now but at least
I have a question accountability and
any momentum over one decade and then
only southern we are more to think about
Isis 2000 Special Tribunal or bekesy
measures that my question is you think
that the international criminal justice
system is still to actually make a
contingency happen okay two things one I
just want to say about this shaving
because I don't want to be misunderstood
in naming and shaming has become a
technology in the human rights movement
okay if you if you if you if you read
any report from Human Rights Watch it's
focused on naming and shaming catalog
the atrocities identify the perpetrators
name and jinglin it is no interest in
history no interest in context no
interest in politics all this is a
distraction okay um well I I think
that's a non-starter
it's complete non-starter I think
however naming and shaming in the case
of the big powers may have some
usefulness that's of a entirely
different note okay
it's one forgot your question
International Criminal Justice I think
we have the cart before the horse you
cannot have an international criminal
justice system unless you have a
credible international order right the
ICC is answerable to the Security
Council if you look at the debates on
the Hague Convention right there are
some very interesting contributions the
contribution of the Indian
representative is worth noting because
he says to the convention that hey look
this Court is accountable to the
Security Council it means it will never
hold accountable any permanent member of
the Security Council simple as that he
was right we don't belong to the
Security Council why should we sign up
that's what he said
I think experience has shown that that's
the case you know if you look at extreme
violence the the real stage of extreme
violence in the world today is the ICC
your expectations were low